as I mentioned yesterday there's a
petition to shut down my speech at
Baylor next week April 9th is the day
the speech the petition has now gathered
I think 17 hundred signatures last I saw
and now there's a second petition to
oppose the petition opposing my speech
and that petition also has 1,700
signatures so we've got a war of the
petitions right now my only hope is that
somebody will now start a petition to
support the petition supporting the
petition opposing the petition and then
of course just to get things really
spicy I'd like for someone to start a
petition opposing the petition
supporting the petition supporting the
petition opposing the petition and and
then you know we'll just we'll just keep
it going until until the day the day of
the speech that would be a lot of fun
there's some other craziness surrounding
the the talk that I want to get into as
well as some other topics as well but
first let's check with our friends from
policy genius it is it's already April
and that's no fooling
[Laughter]
that wasn't had lib I didn't they were I
didn't I won't do that ad-lib again
because that wasn't very good um I could
note for myself time has a habit of
getting away from you that's really the
point here but if you have a mortgage if
you have kids or anyone depending on
your income you're going to have to
spend some of that precious time
getting life insurance and if you need
life insurance but you don't want to
spend a lot of time comparing it and
going through the whole rigmarole of
that then just give policy genius to try
that's the best way to do this and to
save a lot of that precious time policy
genius is the easy way to buy life
insurance online in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price dealing with
insurance is usually really complicated
and to be able to just go on have this
one place where you can go it takes two
minutes you can compare everything that
is a that is like a gift that's manna
from heaven so I would take advantage of
it once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork they'll
handle the handle the red tape so you
don't have to worry about that and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they also make it easy
you find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance any kind
of insurance you can think of there your
one-stop shop for financial protection
so if you need life insurance but you're
short on time head to policy genius.com
and compare quotes their policy genius
easy saves you money not to belabor the
point but it's also fast policy genius
spend less time comparing life insurance
and more time doing literally anything
else in fact you could with policy
genius compare life insurance in a much
in a time that's much quicker than it
took me to even read all that copy all
right
so local media down in Waco did a report
last night apparently about my Baylor
speech and there are a few funny things
about the reports I want to play if it's
not too self-indulgent and it is a
little bit but I'm gonna play this news
report about it well about me honestly
but there's a couple funny points here
so I want you to watch this words breaks
out on social media over a controversial
right-wing speaker
good evening I'm Tara Mergener and I'm
Gordon Collier he's scheduled to talk
next week on the Baylor campus about
traditional family values
news 10's john carroll joins us with
more on this brewing controversy as a
self-proclaimed theocratic fascist a
popular blogger and his official Baylor
event scheduled for April the 9th is
drawing anger by many in the lgbtq+
family so 1 Baylor grad has started a
petition online calling for Baylor to
cancel Walsh's appearance they're not
trying to stoke controversy but um we
figured it might get controversial so
then Allen is a member Baylor young
Americans for freedom it's his group who
got official approval from Baylor to
host Matt Walsh at a free event on
campus waltz describes himself as having
controversial and provocative insights
into culture politics and religion this
one is supposed to be the LGBTQ rainbow
flag with the with the hammer and sickle
on on it but these Flyers placed all
over campus advertising the event say
that whilst will be speaking on how the
left has set out to redefine life gender
and marriage
and it's the hammer and sickle over an
attempt at the LGBTQ flag that some say
is inflammatory baylor alum patrick hill
ii of austin has started an online
petition to urge baylor to cancel the
event he says quote i started the
petition to raise awareness about
something that I proceeded to be blatant
and harmful hate speech my goal is to
have our concerns reach Baylor officials
so that they could reconsider having
Walsh's anti lgbtq+ message as an
official Baylor event Allen says his
group has no doubts the event will go on
as planned and he's gonna be coming and
we're gonna be having a great event so
you're more than welcome to come come
and see what he's gonna be talking about
and he'll definitely be here and he'll
says he's exercising his rights and
starting the online petition but doesn't
want things to get ugly he says quote my
goal is to always speak and act with
love and compassion first and foremost
like Christ has taught me to now we also
reached out to Baylor and this is what
we received quotes as an institution of
higher education we are committed to a
thoughtful exchange of ideas and an
academic environment that supports
inquiry discourse and diversity as a
Christian institution we have an
additional responsibility to appreciate
differing opinions and backgrounds in a
respectful loving manner that extends
grace as Christ did and I also reached
out to groups on the Baylor campus who
said that Walsh's messages at times
target them and they chose not to speak
out on the matter reporting live in the
studio John Carroll kwx news 10 first of
all I want to be very clear about this I
don't know who that beardless weirdo is
in the picture that you saw there but
it's not me that picture has been
photoshopped
I would never humiliate myself by going
around naked face like that so I just I
I completely disavow that picture that
beardless picture second and this I'm
actually serious about the the ads
around campus with the rainbow flag and
the hammer and sickle I have nothing to
do with that perhaps people who don't
understand how these things work might
be confused on this point but when a
student group invites you to come give
speech on campus you don't micromanage
the Flyers they put around campus you're
not you're not sitting there like all
right show me all the fliers where you
where you gonna put that one I can put
in the dorm okay that's just not how it
works
I'm doing five events this month I have
no idea how any of them are advertising
and so that's just the way it is if I
were gonna make my own fliers I wouldn't
I wouldn't choose those but what's done
is done
third and also say that to me the the
rainbow flag is not some sort of sacred
symbol that can't be desecrated and I
don't consider it I don't think it's a
symbol that symbolizes all people who
happen to be homosexual it is a symbol
of the gay lobby you know it's the
symbol of the LGBTQ lobby and that lobby
as I've said many times and I will say
again at Baylor the LGBTQ Lobby is quite
possibly the most vicious bullying
organization in the country with the
tactics that they use third theocratic
fascist there's evidently a lot of hay
being made with the fact that I
self-identify as a theocratic fascist
which yes it does say that in my Twitter
bio and that fact is not only mentioned
in the media report but there was a
there was an article in Baylor student
newspaper written by someone who's been
pulling down flyers for the event and
he's defending his behavior and I think
the title of the article was why I'm
pulling down flyers for the Matt Walsh
event at Baylor something a creative
title like that and he says in part in
his article in the Student News paper he
says um here's one reason I pulled down
the flyers I respect the integrity of
America's governmental systems allowing
self-described fascists to speak on our
campus is not allowing them to exercise
their freedom of speech rather it is
allowing one whose relationship to
freedom is already dubious a platform to
potentially undermine the authority of
the US government and constitution what
so allowing me to speak at Baylor would
undermine the authority of the US
government and the Constitution
I'm not sure I can quite connect those
dots but you know frankly I didn't read
the whole article so maybe he explains
it later on why does it say that in my
bio it does say in my Twitter bio that
I'm a theocratic fascist well because a
few months ago someone sent me a message
trying to insult me
and the message said hey you know you
should put theocratic fascist in your
Twitter bio because that's what you are
and I said okay and I did and and that's
why it's there that's all story now you
could interpret it one of two ways you
see theocratic fascist of my Twitter bio
you could you could say well clearly
that's a sarcastic joke making fun of
all the people who call him a fascist in
a theocratic without knowing what either
of those words mean so you could
interpret it that way or you could say
oh wow he is literally a theocratic
fascist who actually identifies that way
on Twitter completely sincerely with no
sarcasm you could interpret it either
way which interpretation is correct
well obviously the latter I am literally
a theocratic fascist I do indeed believe
that my religious beliefs should be
forced on people by the government and
not just the government but a government
headed by me as a dictator that and
that's just my opinion okay and not just
my religious beliefs but really all of
my beliefs I want everything I believe
to be forced on you by compulsion for
instance I recently went on a tirade on
on Twitter against white condiments
I am racist against white condiments
mayo cream cheese ricotta tartar sauce
ranch dressing all of it is garbage all
of it is for low IQ people frankly and
in my theocratic fascist dictatorship
all of those condiments will be
confiscated prohibited and anyone who is
caught with contraband like say ranch
dressing will face execution and a $50
fine so you see this is really this is
really my whole thing I just believe
that the whole country should be forced
by agents of the state to bend to my
every whim and to live speak and act
exactly as I decree on penalty of death
and you know that's it I'd say it's not
a big deal no it's not like
it's not anything to overreact about I
just I happen to believe that everyone
should be forced to do what I want them
to do and that's just my view you know
we all have our political opinions and
that happens to be mine but I I want to
say this don't worry
because when I complete my takeover of
the country I want to make it very clear
I want to make this very clear ok this
is important my regime will be extremely
corrupt which means that you can always
bribe me and I'll let you pass on most
of the rules for instance you know under
normal circumstances this is a
theocratic fascist dictatorship remember
so those who don't go to church on
Sunday will be burned at the stake
usually now if you pay me money I'll
probably let it go because I you know
because it will be a very morally
corrupt regime I'm just I cannot stress
that enough
so it's not like I my mercy cannot be
bought and and that's all it's like
everyone's freaking out about it say oh
you're gonna burn us at the stake yeah
well if you pay me I won't so what's
that mean what's the big deal here and I
can only hope that the next media report
makes sure to include that I do believe
in burning people at the stake for not
going to church or for using ranch
dressing or for any number of literally
hundreds of infractions and I can only
hope that is so so that I just wanted to
make that clarification all right let's
see here a couple of things to talk
about Joe Biden I don't actually care
about that at all so I'm gonna skip that
let's talk about croissants instead I
think that's more important our friend
AOC Alexandria Kaiser Court says she
tweeted this yesterday here's the tweet
look at this she says croissants at
LaGuardia are going for seven dollars a
piece
scared face emoji yet some people think
getting a whole hour of personal
dedicated human labor for $15 is too
expensive first of all is there anything
more millennial then complain
about the price of croissants at the
airport is there any could you possibly
come up with a more millennial tweet
than that I guess if she was complaining
about the price of avvocato toast that
would be the more maybe slightly more
millennial but this is this is pretty
close to the top also wait a second but
didn't a OC tell us that the world is
coming to an end in part because of air
travel and that she wants to ban air
travel
because of what it's doing to the planet
but now she's at an airport and rather
than being you know rather than weeping
over all of the carbon emissions rather
than staring out of the big Airport
windows at all the planes going by and
and weeping uncontrollably at how these
carbon emissions are killing the planet
no she's in the she's at the snack bar
worried about croissants so this doesn't
make any sense and every time I bring
this up people act like it's some kind
of cheap tactic you know any time you
bring up the fact that oh you got these
environmentalists who are still out
there flying on planes and driving in
cars everything and when you bring that
up people act like it's it's just a
gotcha it's a gotcha thing like yeah you
know whatever but no it's it's this is a
this is a real point that if you if you
say that air travel is killing the
planet and it should be banned because
of it well then you can't go on using
planes yourself because if you do that
we are going to suspect that you don't
really mean it that you're not sincere
because if you were sincere then this at
the very least using an airplane should
be a source of should be a moral crisis
for you the fact that you're on an
airplane taking part in this I mean if
you ever use an airplane if you really
think that airplanes are killing the
planet and you and you use one it should
be only in extreme circumstances and you
should be as I said you should really be
crying out of guilt the entire time that
the fact that you're that you're worried
about croissants tells me that you're
not actually that concerned about the
planet being killed by airplanes which
which tells me that you don't really
even take yourself seriously and finally
of course how much do you think those
croissants would cost
if the people putting them into little
baggies and handing them to you had to
be paid $15 an hour to do so assuming
this was not a homemade croissant place
at the airport which probably wasn't
I've had many Airport croissants in my
day because I'm a millennial as well and
I do like croissants
I'll admit and in almost every case they
are not made at the scene so so if you
think that the person who's just taking
it out of the little glass case and
putting it into the bag and handing it
if that job of doing this you know
that's all it is to taking it boom here
put your card in you know and then
that's it here's your receipt if you
think that job should at a minimum be
paid $15 an hour then how much do you
think those croissants are gonna cost
you you know meanwhile since we're on
the topic of the minimum wage a bill in
Arizona is actually looking to reduce
the minimum wage from $11 to 725 but
only for workers under 22 years of age
and the logic there is that the vast
majority of workers between the ages of
16 and 22 don't have any dependents that
most of them are living at home they're
not married they don't have kids and so
you know some of them do have kids but
for the man the vast majority do not
statistically and so if the minimum wage
is a little lower then you could hire
more young people give more people that
work experience but you don't have to
pay them as if they have kids to take
care of because almost none of them do
and that makes a lot of sense to me
though I think the minimum wage should
be should be lowered to zero for
everyone the minimum wage should be zero
because the minimum usefulness for an
employee is zero if not actually in the
negative because an employee could cost
you money without you know so it but
let's just say for the sake of argument
it's zero what I mean is there are some
workers who simply aren't worth $15 an
hour or or 11 or seven or five and
thinking and when I say that I don't
mean all of the workers who were
customer service or behind a cash
register my point is I'm not I don't
want to lump them all together way when
you talk about $15 minimum wage you are
lumping them all together you're saying
you're saying they're all worth exactly
the same $15 I don't think that so when
I you know if I go to Wendy's or
something and and and I see you know
someone who came to work without their
shirt even tucked in moping around
moving as slow as molasses scowl on the
face making the whole experience
miserable for everybody you know that is
someone whose value to the company is
simply the fact that they can push a
button and that's it they quit because
they bring nothing else to the table at
all and there are people like that know
that we've all experienced not exerting
themselves not trying any they are not
trying to do anything but just pretty
even pressing the button they get wrong
and they do it as slow as they possibly
can almost like they're trying to make a
point that they're not going to rush for
you and I think they're patient at I
think that's fair
and it should reflect that in part so
that the people who go the extra mile
and work hard and exert themselves can
be paid in a way that reflects that as
I've said before I think the situation
should be by have the situation behind
any fast food counter should be this
that there are people behind that
counter making 50 cents an hour and
there should be other people behind that
counter who are making $30 an hour
that's what it should be there should be
because that's how wide the chasm is
between the most on the ball employee
and the least on the ball employee
that's how why the chasm is a night and
I think the patient reflected it
shouldn't be that everyone who happens
to work behind a cash register at a
fast-food place or at a mall food stand
that you know they all get paid exactly
the same because they're not all they
aren't all the same
so people like Alexander kzo Cortez who
want to you know raise the minimum wage
they can pretend to be the compassionate
ones who are concerned about you know
making making sure people have more
money and all that but but really with
the system I am talking about the people
who really work hard in those jobs could
make a lot more money than they do now
and they should all right this is
interesting
Jake Tapper's daughter Alice has
apparently written a book called raise
your hand and the book is encouraging
girls to raise their hands in school and
she says there's a problem with girls
not participating in school while boys
do participate and so here she is on CNN
with her dad promoting the book I have
to tell you I love the book thank you
and I love the story behind it so just
tell us how you came to write this well
I started noticing in class that the
boys were raising their hands more than
the girls and the girls were just
sitting there being silent and I was
scared myself to raise my hand so I
brought this up to my mom because I want
to know if I was the only one she told
me to go ask my Girl Scout trip so then
I went to my Girl Scout troop to ask
them if they've experienced the same and
notices notice that the boys were
raising their hands more than the girls
they said that they also experienced
shyness well and raising their hands so
I wanted to do something about that so I
gotten them in a meeting with the Girl
Scouts nation's capitals council Lydia
so to Herman and we discussed what we
could do with this information so I had
the idea of making a patch for Girl
Scouts to earn okay I think it's great
that she wrote the book
just want to be clear about that I think
it's great sure what the book I'm not
criticizing her the Girl Scout badge
thing is is great good stuff there I do
have to say though my experience
this is what interests me about that my
experience was exactly the opposite of
this exactly opposite as a student and
now as a parent as a student my memory
is that the girls were almost always the
ones who were raising their hands and
participating and it's usually the boys
who for various different reasons we're
not participating myself included and I
can say with my daughter who's five
years old she is much more outspoken and
wanting to participate in things and
answer questions than her five-year-old
brother who himself is not some sort of
you know shy shrinking violet I mean she
but he but he she's just more like that
so and and I thought this was kind of
sort of accepted by everyone this fact
that girls are the ones who are raising
their hands and participating in school
and usually it's boys who are not and
it's boys who need to be encouraged to
participate so that's what that's what
interests me I mean you know she's
writing a book great but obviously
there's some publisher who thought yeah
you know we need a we need a book and
specifically encouraging girls which
which fine I mean you know all that
stuff is good but I do every time I see
this kind of thing I think what why
don't why is why is it that all the
encouragement I get that Alice Tapper
would she's a girl herself she wants to
encourage her female classmates great
but I would like to see some publishers
maybe start publishing books encouraging
boys specifically in school because it
seems like they are really the ones who
need it most of the time I mean I guess
there are some girls who were shy know
participate and struggle I don't deny
that but generally speaking I mean any
measurable you look at will show you
that it is definitely boys who struggle
in the school system as opposed to girls
boys are the ones who have the most
problems and you can look at that based
on the dropout rate boy versus girl look
at you know average GPA look at you
you know the ones who normally get
suspended look at the ones who are most
likely to be diagnosed ADHD it's just
it's boys boys boys boys down the line
for those things disciplinary problems
usually boys I mean just across the
board so I would be interested for any
teachers I know that there are a fair
amount of teachers watch the show they
listen to the show I appreciate that
what's your experience as I said my
experience is it's almost always girls
who are the ones who are participating
and who seem to really enjoy school and
are really you know into it as opposed
to boys and so if you're a teacher I'd
be interested interested in your
experience do you find that it's
generally girls or boys and it's not a
competition but I do think it's
important because as I said there does
seem to be a hole in the market here
where there's always a ton of stuff
encouraging girls awesome but I really
think the guys need some encouragement
too I really do especially in school
because I think they're having a tough
time then they have been for a long time
and that tends to be ignored all right
let's go check the inbox Matt wall show
at gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
this is from Brandon says Matt thank you
so much for taking on the heaven hell
question today on your podcast I loved
your response and I think the believers
the world over need to revisit the
shallow idea of who is in and who is out
thank you thank you thank you
Thank You Brandon your sentiments were
not shared by everyone as I will now
demonstrate from laura's as Matt I enjoy
listening to almost everything you speak
about but just cringe when you try to
explain things about Christianity
actually I want to scream as I listened
to your twisted view on many of those
things please stick the politics or news
or sports etc believe anything related
to Christianity or the Bible for others
I really hope your listeners do their
own studying and research and don't take
you at your word for example the Bible
explains very clearly how you get to
heaven it doesn't say that as long as
you love you can go there I realize that
Catholics have a lot of twisted beliefs
as in infant baptism communion praying
to Mary etc so please don't try to
convince your listeners that what you
believe is biblical please warn them
that it is your beliefs and not biblical
thanks Laura well thank you mom for that
for that for that instruction from from
you I do appreciate it and thank you for
telling me the things that I should talk
about in the things that I shouldn't you
know that is Laura I would tell you that
that is the best way to get me to take
you seriously is to start your email
with I am going to tell you the things
you're allowed to talk about are the
things that you out here are the
approved subjects and this is unapproved
stop talking about that especially when
you know I've been doing this for five
years and talking about faith has been
like my main thing but you're saying no
if don't talk about that anymore so
again very much appreciate the
anti-catholic stuff at the end and
really solid as well so just you really
put that together in a way that's going
to want you know make me want to engage
with you I may be very sarcastic I just
want to make that clear but Laura's
email is representative and you just so
you know you know if you do want to
engage with someone on theology it's
probably best not to tell them yet to
start with that they shouldn't be
talking about it and then also to throw
in you know those nasty little insults
at the end but the large emails
representative of many others I received
here's the interesting thing though I
posed the question on the show can love
exist in hell that was the question yeah
it's an interesting question isn't it
that's also it's it's a question
something we can talk about or is Hell a
place devoid of lobby can-can luck and
love exists in Hell or is it a place
devoid of love those seem to be two
mutually exclusive possibilities now
Laura like many of the emails I received
that were similar in tone Laura made no
attempt to answer that question or
engage with it
she didn't at all she just said stop
talking about this and I I cannot tell
you how much I despise that attitude not
lorem despise you Laura but that
attitude of I'm not going to engage with
what you said I'm just gonna tell you
not to talk about it I really hate that
attitude
I think it's a
double attitude because we need to be
talking about these things so Laura's at
so Laura's approach is just to shout
about the Bible but the Bible says this
without proper without providing any
citations whatsoever just to say the
Bible says it and then Bible says that
you're wrong shut up but I imagine that
if I had simply stated hell is a place
devoid of love but if I had just said
that and I just left it there and I said
you know hell is a place the void of
love is it's a place separate from from
love hell is a loveless place if I had
said all that Laura and everyone else
listening they everyone would have
approved and they would have said sure
yeah I wouldn't have gotten any angry
emails well it's just when I tried to
talk about what that might mean see it's
it's easy to just say something it's
just a talking point as a slogan and so
yeah there's no love in Hell right okay
well can we take it a step further and
talk about what does that mean exactly
what what do we do with that information
where do we get that idea from
or do you want to just stay on surface
level because I think staying on the
surface level I don't see the point in
that I'd like to go deeper and talk
about what these things mean I could sit
here all day and just shout Christian
slogans at you but I'm have no interest
in doing that I want to talk about what
does all that stuff mean so I say again
hell is either a place where love cannot
exist or it is a place where even the
virtuous and loving may be tormented for
all time one of those answers is correct
right hell is devoid of love or does not
if it is devoid of love then we get back
to my original question what about
someone who didn't come to know God in
life but did come to love as best they
can agape love real love not just
emotional affection but really came to
love someone someone else and they did
come to love they were capable of love
they were a loving person what about
someone like that will that loving
person be cast into the furnace for all
time can they be
I mean logically is it possible for if
if hell is a place without love
Kenny can love even for lack of a better
term can love even fit there can it
exist there as I said a lot of people
criticized my thoughts on that very few
actually attempted to answer the
question Laura said the Bible is clear
about who goes to heaven I find that
most of the time when people start a
sentence by saying the Bible is very
clear about blank 95% of time that's a
good indication that that person has
never read the Bible has never seriously
studied it because the Veit the Bible is
clear about some things yes but on many
things the answer you get in the Bible
is very complex and dense and sometimes
confusing and and that's why theologians
and philosophers have been studying it
for studying it for thousands of years
and that's why by the way there are
about 50,000 divisions in the church
with everyone convinced of the rightness
of their theological interpretation
because actually maybe it's not quite as
simple as Laura here seems to think I
mean at what point do you look around
you and say well wow I mean all these
people have vastly different
interpretations of what they read in the
Bible everyone is completely convinced
that they're right and so maybe you know
we need to go back and look at it again
maybe it's not quite that simple or it
could be just that everyone is an idiot
except for you I mean that's that's the
other possibility but you know I I'm not
going to make that assumption it's true
that the Bible never says that loving
people can't go to hell the Bible never
says a lot of things there are a lot of
things that we take for granted as being
true that the Bible never says and I
could sit here all day listing them for
instance the
says slavery is wrong in fact it
arguably says the opposite so but but we
we all agree that slavery is wrong right
I mean unless you want to argue
otherwise
you're not going to find any direct
support for that in the Bible you won't
that's a fact but you feel confident
making that same why is that as for hell
the Bible actually through the vast
majority of its pages says nothing about
Hell and when I say the vast majority
through the entire Old Testament which
makes up most of the Bible in terms of
quantity pages that there is nothing
about hell then Jesus comes and he talks
about Hell quite a bit I think he talked
about how old more than he talks about
heaven so it is so there's no question
that as Christians we believe in hell
because Jesus says it but even when
Jesus talks about Hell he uses several
different words for it he he and he
doesn't at any point say okay listen
here's how you go to hell
here's how you go to heaven here's the
fine print here are all the particulars
I'm gonna lay it all out for you he
doesn't do that he really doesn't do
that with hardly any topic at all he
does say this though in Matthew chapter
7 he says not everyone who says to me
Lord Lord will enter the kingdom of
heaven but the one who does the will of
my father who is in heaven on that day
many will say to me Lord Lord we did not
prophesy or we did we not prophesy on
your name and cast out demons your name
and do many mighty works in your name
and then I will declare to them I never
knew you depart from me you workers of
lawlessness depart from me you workers
of lawlessness and some interpretations
have evildoers depart from me you evil
doers so that's what Jesus just look at
this again Jesus says the ones that are
getting kicked out here are the workers
of lawlessness and the ones who go in
are the ones who do the will of my
father in heaven Paul says this
first corinthians and said if I speak in
the tongues of men or of angels but do
not have love I am only a resounding
gong or a clanging cymbal if I have the
gift of prophecy and can fathom all
mysteries and all knowledge and if I
have a faith that can move mountains but
do not have love I am nothing if I give
all I possess to the poor and give over
my body to hardship that I may boast but
do not have love I gain nothing then it
goes on love is patient love is kind we
know that part it does not envy it does
not boast I'm not gonna skip over it
actually it's beautiful it is not proud
it does not dishonor others it is not
self-seeking it is not easily angered it
keeps no record of wrongs love does not
delight in evil but rejoices with the
truth it always protects always trusts
always hopes always perseveres love
never fails and now these three remain
Faith Hope and love but the greatest of
these is love
okay so Jesus says that those who engage
in empty acts of a religious piety those
who profess faith may be cast cast out
Paul says that it's a lack of love which
causes that emptiness Paul also says
that love is greater than faith faith is
important but love is greater so what
about someone then who has no faith but
has the greater thing what do we do
about them the person who declared faith
in Jesus but was empty of love a
whitewashed tomb Jesus calls them at
another point inscription could be sent
to hell what about someone who did not
declare faith yet was full of love I
don't know but it's an interesting
question isn't it it's definitely a
question that if you if you confront
that question and you immediately go
stupid no then you're not you're not
taken seriously I don't I don't think
you're a serious person frankly and if
you say the Bible is clear on that then
you haven't read it the question
complex then you understand in that case
and the Bible is more complicated than
you realize because I don't think you've
seriously studied it keep in mind as I
said yesterday that you cannot love
without loving God there is no such
thing as love apart from God really
Jesus says you only get to heaven
through him
that part is clear but is it possible to
get there through him without realizing
it that's the question I got a lot of
email saying well the Bible is clear
Jesus is the way the truth and life well
yeah it is but what does that mean
though I mean what does that consist of
Jesus is the door to eternal life yes
but but right
Jesus decides who goes to heaven we all
go through him is it possible for
someone who didn't realize they were
going to heaven through him to still do
so is that a is that a determination
that Jesus can make are you prepared to
say that Jesus cannot make that
determination are you prepared to
declare that he never will and never did
I'm not so is it possible to love God
without being fully conscious of the
fact that you are loving him if God is
love then all love true love is of God I
didn't say that love is God I said all
God is love therefore all love is of God
all true love is of God so it seems to
me that a person may love with a love
that is of God which is just another way
of saying it's actual real love without
being fully cognizant of it and Jesus
who is the way the truth and life may
admit someone through those doors who
will be surprised by the fact and just
as there are gonna be people who expect
to be admitted but won't be that's what
I see in the text and that's also I
think a logical conclusion based on our
understanding of Hell that's when I say
I'm trying to we get we can throw verses
at each other all day but at a certain
point you got to take the concept and
try to understand them what does this
actually mean if keep something one
other thing here if you're of the
opinion that only those who consciously
affirm Christ can go to heaven and that
for some reason that mental affirmation
is all that matters
then as we've talked about before by
that logic every dead baby is in hell
every single one every Jew who died in
the Holocaust is in hell and many of the
Nazis who sent them there are in heaven
now Nazism was not a Christian invention
by any means it was an atheist invention
but there's no question about the fact
that many individual Nazis were
Christian and bad Christians evil people
but Christian so this is the implication
of a belief that puts conscious
affirmation of Christ as the highest and
really only qualification the problem is
that belief not only leads to utterly
monstrous conclusions like the one that
I've described here but it simply
doesn't wash with the two verses I just
read you know with Jesus there that to
me is the clearest statement in the
Bible about how you get to heaven is
that right there cuz it's from Jesus's
mouth and he's saying here it is
but even that it did take some
understanding you get a look at it in
context and everything so even that
isn't quite as simple as it seems but
that that's as simple as it gets I think
the problem is some people they like to
overlook what Jesus said on certain
matters by finding various quotes in the
Pauline epistles and then stitching
together kind of a road to get around
what Jesus said well we could do that I
mean we can have a verse war like a food
fight fighting back and forth oh yeah
well says this here it says that there
back and forth here's my verse here's
that we can do that you know we can or
we can try to come to a more cohesive
understanding of the entire text and of
our faith by dealing with these subjects
on a deeper level you know and so that's
what I choose to do let's see I got a
bunch of emails I just spent way too
much time on that one from Jonathan no
offense but after listening to your show
today on on said topic I was wondering
how much of the New Testament you've
read Jesus tells a literal story of a
man that is in hell and looks up at
Beggs Abraham to give him a drop of
water
when Abraham refuses the man selflessly
and I would say lovingly begs for
family to be warned which has refused
that one story from Jesus himself
completely contradicts your entire
statement which I would say is based
purely on conjecture since you didn't
quote one verse that being said keep up
the interesting dialogue Jonathan I
don't mean to be pedantic but that was
not a literal story it was a parable
that Jesus told and that's not just my
assumption that's definitely in context
a parable Jesus wasn't saying that this
literal thing actually happened and I'm
telling you a you know biographical
story about this guy Lazarus it was a
parable so the question is what are we
meant to learn from it is that the point
that Jesus was trying to make that a
loving guy might go to hell
no I think exactly the opposite actually
that story I think completely supports
my point of view how is it that the rich
man ended up in hell what did he do
wrong was it that he didn't believe in
God no it was nothing that was never
mentioned
Jesus never never said anything about
the rich man's faith he ended up in hell
because he was greedy and he was sitting
at his table eating all the food never
never feeding Lazar he showed no love or
generosity to Lazarus that's why he went
to hell in the parable he was an
unloving greedy person that's how he
ended up there never said anything about
what he believed anything about it said
nothing about that he got there because
he was a greedy selfish sob and I think
that's the point we're trying that we
get from that I don't think the point
was that he was really a loving guy
because if that's the case then we read
the parable again well then how did he
ended up well why was he there and we
can be pretty
it's not a literal story because I don't
think that people in hell are actually
carrying on conversations with with
people in heaven I don't think it works
that way because in fact in that parable
it says that there's an unbridgeable
chasm between the two which i think
tells us that we're not if you're in
hell you're not going to be carrying on
conversations with the people who are
not there finally let's see this is from
Bryce as good afternoon Matt your beard
is weak grow a bigger one Bryce I have
received a lot of vicious hate mail in
my day but that just goes beyond the
pill and it you know what it tells me it
tells me that you Bryce must not be a
beardsman because a true beardsman would
never beard shame another beardsman so
so I think Bryce I think what's
happening here is that you are a
baby-faced clean-shaven person and you
are trying to sow discord and division
in the bearded community with that email
and I'm not gonna fall for it
I just won't how dare you I could grow
it a little bit bigger though I think
you're right about that all right we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching Godspeed
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know young
people have stopped meeting they've
stopped not just having sex but stopped
getting married they're not having
children it's not a good thing does it
have anything to do with leftism you bet
it does I'm Andrew Clavin that's on the
Andrew Clavin show